étudiants pour les plus contestataires
d'entre eux ce long week-end ne sera
qu'une trêve l'action contre la réforme
du second cycle pourrait reprendre dès
mardi l'unef renouveau et les
enseignants regroupés au sein du sne sup
ont confirmé leur intention d'organiser
la semaine prochaine deux nouvelles
journées d'action les représentants de
ces deux mouvements de manque d'à la
coordination nationale des étudiants
coordination réunissent samedi à
toulouse comme elle l'était la semaine
dernière un bien de se rallier à leurs
propositions c'est à dire ces
manifestations la grève générale et une
opération portes ouvertes décision sans
doute demain le président de la
république invité la semaine dernière
son secrétaire d'état a expliqué la
réforme du deuxième cycle ce que madame
saunier séité a fait tout au long de ces
derniers jours mais visiblement sans
être parvenu à débloquer la situation
les étudiants grévistes sont décidés à
durcir le mouvement jusqu'au retrait de
l'arrêté du 16 janvier
ils ont reçu l'appui les présidents
d'université ce qui n'est pas
négligeable
madame saunier séité ne veut pas abrogée
sont arrêtés mais elle est prête à faire
des concessions sur la circulaire
d'application pour l'instant elle a
convaincu la fen fédération de
l'éducation nationale
elle compte aussi sur la pression des
étudiants anti grévistes qui tentent de
s'organiser sans trop de succès jusqu'à
présent la semaine prochaine chaque
parti va se compter si les choses
restent en l'état ou si le rapport de
force s'envenime
il faudra bien trouver une autre
tactique il faudra bien qu'une
initiative soit prise
voir un arbitrage la sphère risque alors
de passer du terrain purement
universitaire au plan politique le
journal times de londres qui a du recul
se demande s'il est même erreur que
celle de mai 68 ne risque pas à la
longue d'être commises par le
gouvernement français le quotidien de
londres juge en tout cas cette affaire
je le cite comme une mise à l'épreuve de
la capacité du président giscard
d'estaing de prendre en main une
situation explosive
il faudrait qu'il faudra donc attendre
quelques jours pour savoir si la
situation est réellement explosive